[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
local media takes center stage and the
chandler hauled us in trial and tonight
we're left to wonder what happened to
barton krista helderson what the
defendant told reporters days before his
parents remains were found and where is
harmony montgomery all efforts are
focused on that harmony is alive and we
are going to do everything we can to
find her the seven-year-old's father is
arrested two years after she was last
seen plus
should an lapd officer face charges the
latest on the deadly shooting inside a
hollywood clothing store and later could
a juror's admission lead to a new trial
for gillane maxwell what a juror
revealed in a new interview law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian brockmeyer along with terry
austin we're learning more about how
defendant chandler halderson acted in
the days after his parents were reported
missing all this just six months before
he stands trial for murdering and
dismembering them both
the 23 year old is charged in the deaths
of bart and crystal hardelson
prosecutors say he murdered them cut up
their bodies with knives and saws and
attempted to burn their remains in the
family fireplace after that he scattered
other parts of their bodies across
southern wisconsin before the remains
were discovered halterson reported his
parents missing to police and told a
similar story to madison wisconsin tv
stations on wednesdays those news
reports took center stage in the
courtroom
the search continues for this couple
krista and bart halderson they live near
deforest they were reported missing
yesterday nbc 15's elise romas joins us
live from the dane county sheriff's
office northeast precinct elise you
spoke with their son and people in the
halderson's neighborhood
[Music]
yeah john the hellerson's son says that
he helped his parents pack up the night
before their trip to their cabin in land
glade county he hasn't seen them since
i was told they would be home monday or
tuesday and
tuesday afternoon i got a little worried
halson told the same story to family
friends adding that his parents went to
their cabin for the fourth of july
weekend on wednesday krista halderson's
best friend told jurors she searched the
halderson family cabin and called the
defendant from that property
he's like did you find anything and i
said like what
and i was shocked that he said
any bullet shells or any blood or
anything and i went
what
and he's like
did you find anything and i'm like no
no one's been here
and he's like
okay what do you think i should do i'm
like you need to report them as missing
obviously they didn't make it here
i don't know how they could go to a
parade if they didn't make it here
but whatever maybe they stayed somewhere
else i didn't know
other family friends took the stand
saying they visited halterson at his
windsor wisconsin home after hearing his
parents were missing
the detectives leave i wanted to go with
them but why um just a weird vibe and
this is just not somewhere
i just didn't feel very safe like i
i felt um
i don't know how to explain it but this
is it's like i'm sitting in the middle
of what now seems to be a crime scene
with somebody who is acting differently
than i'm used to
and it just doesn't feel like a good
idea
in the moment he told me you know
they're probably just at a casino
what did you think of that comment
there's no way
there's just no way that
they are like
just
the sweetest loving people you ever meet
and there is no way that
you know they would have ever put anyone
that they love or care about in a
situation
where they're worried about where they
are
joining us today is legal analyst kirk
nermey and terry austin kirk hindsight
is 2020 but all of these witnesses seem
to be pointing at the very least to red
flags about hollison and his parents but
how do red flags turn into a conviction
for the prosecution
yeah brian if there's such a thing as an
ordinary murder this certainly isn't one
of them right because the defendant in
this case is accused of not only killing
his parents
dismembering the body burning body parts
scattering across the state that makes
him a particular kind of gruesome that
makes him a particular kind of monster
right so
for the story to be complete the state
in this case has to prove that not just
the murder but his post murder actions
were consistent with the story with this
monstrous behavior so i think all these
friends and family members and we see
his actions post uh post-murder kind of
help illustrate that the eerie feelings
they got that sort of thing all helped
paint the picture of this defendant as a
monster yeah it definitely sets that
kind of mood as it continues terry in
the defense's opening they said look for
what's missing look for alternatives are
you seeing anything missing or any
alternatives here
brian i'll tell you what's missing the
entire defense is missing when i listen
into that opening it was the most
generic opening i've ever seen they
didn't mention any facts they didn't
mention any evidence and in fact that's
because the evidence against the
defendant is overwhelming all the
defense talked about in the opening was
what his constitutional rights might be
what the burden of proof is as far as
the prosecution is concerned they did
not assert any alternate theory at all
whatsoever in fact what they told the
jury is when this case is over you're
gonna have no answers i've never heard
an opening where they tell the jury
you're not gonna know what happened the
worst defense opening i've ever heard
yeah that's what many defense attorneys
call a non-opening opening hopefully in
the summation they put together
some facts that point to some reasonable
doubt if they expect or hope for a not
guilty verdict in this case also in
wisconsin a man said to be tried in the
death of a prominent milwaukee attorney
is denied bail just days after his jury
trial was postponed due to covet
concerns theodore edgecombe is accused
of killing immigration attorney jason
clearman last year in milwaukee and what
police are calling a road rage incident
edgecombe's defense attorneys claim he
acted in self-defense they argue
clearman's car which his wife was
driving at the time tried to run edgcomb
off the road while he was on his bike
the criminal complaint says the two got
into a fight and edgecombe allegedly
punched clearman through the open
passenger side window then clearman
later got out of the car and edgecombe
shot him edgecombe claims clearman had a
knife the prosecution says he fled the
state he was arrested six months later
in kentucky edgecombe appeared in a
virtual bond hearing on wednesday where
defense attorneys argued it would be
safer for him to be released things got
heated when judge david borowski said
to the attorneys that this hearing was
not the time to litigate the case
every expert in america would agree
that the safest place for mr edgecombe
to be would be home
to ensure that he is healthy and that he
will be able to stand trial come january
18th
number two um you know there's been
other material differences as it um as
the evidence
has come about in this case number one
the video um there's complete video
evidence which will tend to show at
least arguably that mr ascombe acted
reasonably um in that any force that was
used was completely in self-defense also
looking at the strength of the state's
case um i mean we've attached to the
motion that was filed which is a short
motion but also pictures of the knife
that was located on mr clearman's person
he was armed with an eight and a half
inch knife with a serrated blade so we
have attached that i did have a chance
to inspire hang on hang on mr mod just
like i said to mrs lamar i don't want to
try the case the case is set for trial
in two weeks we're not trying it today
and i don't want to try it specifically
with the media here to listen so that it
can go and be sensationalized what
evidence comes in during the trial i
will rule on at the appropriate time
don't litigate this any further in front
of the media when the only issue here
today is bail
the trial is scheduled to begin on
january 18th
still ahead on law and crime daily calls
for a california police officer to
resign or be charged over the shooting
of a 14 year old in a burlington coat
factory but first movement in new
hampshire after a girl who hasn't been
seen in two years was recently reported
missing we bring you the latest
developments as an arrest is made in the
case
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back the father of a
seven-year-old girl who's been missing
for more than two years now faces
charges and appears in court in new
hampshire long crimes agent levy is here
with the details
brian it's really unbelievable but the
police chief in manchester new hampshire
says no one has seen harmony montgomery
since october of 2019.
now her father adam montgomery is
charged with second-degree assault
interfering with custody and endangering
the welfare of a child adam montgomery
is accused of hitting harmony in the eye
in 2019 and giving her a black eye court
documents state adam montgomery's
brother told police he was abusive
toward his daughter by spanking her hard
making her stand in the corner for hours
and forcing her to clean a toilet with
her own toothbrush the brother also told
police that adam montgomery admitted to
bashing harmony around the house
harmony's mother reported her missing
last month saying she had tried to find
her but lost custody of her in 2018 to
adam montgomery because she had a
substance abuse problem
manchester's police chief pleaded with
anyone with information about harmony's
whereabouts to come forward
i'm appealing to everyone
help us find this little girl
someone knows something
do what is right and call in
i cannot emphasize that enough
somebody out there knows something
it's time for people to do the right
thing
i cannot say it enough i cannot
emphasize it enough
someone needs to call in do the right
thing
and provide us information on where
harmony may be
now adam montgomery's bail he actually
waived his arraignment and he's being
held without bail at this time there was
an agreement made between his attorney
and the attorney general's office on
that bail and with the court and it
appears that adam montgomery according
to people who knew him also had
substance abuse problems there is a 33
thousand 000 reward for anyone who can
provide information to harmony about
harmony's whereabouts and what happened
to her and there is also a tip line you
can call or text 603-203-6060
brian
thank you manchester and of course if
you have any information about harmony
make sure to follow up on that number
let's bring back legal analyst kirk
nurmi and terry austin to discuss the
latest in the search for harmony terry
how does a five-year-old not seen for
two years be reported by child services
only a week ago make any sense
brian nothing in this case makes sense
to me first of all we know the mother
lost custody in 2018 like angenette said
because of substance abuse and she last
saw the child in 2019 and we know that
the father had custody and that he beat
the child and we know that the father's
uncle reported all this we know that the
brother reported some of the abuse as
well so we also know that the child had
been in child services in two different
states massachusetts and new hampshire
so all of these people had some contact
with this child and yet
she hadn't been seen for two years it
just doesn't make sense every single
person in this case dropped the ball and
it is a complete failure now kirk based
on the charges what can we assume the
prosecution believes and why no charges
more serious than the assault
well i think we can believe that the
prosecution believes exactly what
they've put out in the indictment that
they have evidence of abuse neglect all
those sort of things now you ask you
know why no no further charges i think
he's been arrested on these charges and
hope to put pressure on him so that
maybe he will be more forthcoming or
somehow crack as it relates to the other
charges but for now why none because one
we don't have proof of death right like
terry just said nothing in this case
makes sense we don't have proof of death
yeah you know there's cases that can go
forward without a body there's been
murder cases that do go forward in that
regard but i think before they charge
before they feel like they have a strong
case the authorities in this case want
to go back over those two missing years
and really nail it down hard unless they
can get him to confess in a custodial
situation makes sense now and jeanette
manchester police had contact with
harmony back in 2019 right
that's right they went to a home where
she was living at the time and we are
only being told at this time by the
police chief that it was a call for
service and that police had contact with
harmony but they're really not releasing
any um other information about that call
and when the police chief was asked
whether or not there was some type of
law enforcement breakdown or failure he
said that would be dealt with when the
time is appropriate so you have to
believe that something went terribly
wrong here well let's hope bringing
light to this case gets more answers
both for the family and the police thank
you all coming up on law and crime daily
protesters called for the arrest of a
los angeles police officer after the
shooting death of a 14 year old girl
plus could elaine maxwell's conviction
be overturned why jeffrey epstein's
former girlfriend could have a chance at
a new trial
[Music]
welcome back protesters are calling for
a los angeles police officer to be fired
or arrested after the fatal shooting of
a 14 year old girl two weeks ago
two days before christmas officer
william jones jr responded to 9-1-1
calls of a man assaulting women at a
burlington coat factory in north
hollywood several of those callers told
dispatchers they suspected the man had a
gun police say daniel elena lopez did
not have a firearm at the scene but had
assaulted several women with a metal
bike lock
body camera video shows the moment
officers arrived and when they fatally
shot lopez fourteen-year-old valentina
orlando peralta was in the store's
fitting room with her mother when jones
fired his weapon that fitting room was
right behind the suspect peralta was
shot and died as a result of her
injuries jones is on paid leave while
the incident is being investigated civil
rights attorney ben crump who has
recently been on the spotlight for
representing the families of george
floyd and ahmad arbury is representing
the peralta family
back with us as legal analysts kirk
nermey and co-host terry austin to
discuss the latest in this tragic loss
out of l.a terry as demonstrators call
for action what potential civil and
criminal charges could officer william
jones jr face
well in california on the criminal side
he could really face involuntary
manslaughter and all they would have to
show there is that you know he killed
another resulting in death and it was
without mouse without intent and it
involved a high risk of death and i
think an argument can be made that
shooting in a crowded store does involve
high risk of death there's a chance that
you could definitely hit someone else
and on the civil side we already saw
that ben crump is already working with
the family there could be a lawsuit for
a wrongful death action to recover
compensation by the family for this loss
so definitely facing some charges both
civil and criminal
absolutely now kirk a third angle is
that the result of the tragedy could
see changes in police procedures do you
think things could or should change in
la policing after this
well definitely you know and terry hit
on the key point right shooting in an
open store what kind of risk does that
cause because while the police came in
in a high-risk situation
they didn't you know there were some
callers that said there was a gun there
were some that didn't so while it was a
high-risk situation there was no
confirmation of a weapon and it turns
out there wasn't one so i think things
like this before one starts shooting in
a crowded store that have to be
considered because of this tragedy
certainly this young victim was not a
target of this man but certainly his
actions could be considered reckless in
the situation given that he is in a
crowded department store of course
changes are going to depend on what all
the body cameras and all the store
footage show but ultimately that risk of
shooting bullets into a crowded store is
something i think lapd is going to have
to take a long hard look at yeah but
interesting to see the results of this
case we'll make sure to keep updates as
they continue the recently convicted
british socialite elaine maxwell could
be entitled to a new trial when we come
back how a juror's past could lead to a
motion for mistrial
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
elaine maxwell's defense team could ask
for a new trial after news that a juror
may not have disclosed childhood sexual
abuse to the court
the juror known by his first in middle
name only scotty david told reuters he
opened up about his past abuse only
during deliberations as fellow jurors
questioned the credibility of some
witnesses that's when scottie david told
them he could also only remember some of
the sexual abuse from his childhood he
also said he understood why some
witnesses didn't come forward until
later in life because he told them that
he waited years to admit the abuse to
anyone according to the court records
juror questionnaires asked whether
potential jurors had a history of sexual
abuse scottie david also told reuters
that he flew through the questionnaire
and doesn't remember being asked that
question prior to this news maxwell's
team already indicated it would be
seeking an appeal to the guilty
conviction on wednesday prosecutors
informed judge allison nathan about the
allegations urging for an inquiry
kirk does a juror swaying a jury this
way seem like a legitimate appellate
issue or a phishing expedition by the
defense
i think it's a legitimate issue brian
because you know if we have a juror that
misrepresented himself on the
questionnaire and then you know was
maybe less than forthcoming during war
dyer i mean we have for dyer for a
reason right to ensure that everybody
gets a fair trial and if he wasn't
forthcoming then goes back to the jury
deliberation room and kind of gives
evidence gives his explanation gives an
analogy to the juries in his whole
own experience that's exactly the kind
of thing that a defendant under the
sixth amendment is titled to ferret out
during war dyer so i think we will see
this a motion for a new trial possibly a
inquiry into this and ultimately it will
probably be a part of any appeal that
takes place in this case if it's denied
yeah and you better believe that again
maxwell's defense attorneys knew about
this they would have struck him or off
the bat terry what's the process of
getting to the truth of how the jury
came to his decision would we have a
hearing or some sort of questioning of
this juror
well the first thing the judge is going
to do is schedule an evidentiary hearing
because they're going to want to know
what the juror was questioned about and
what were his answers and actually asked
the juror what was this experience that
you had and they're going to review the
questionnaire the judge is going to ask
questions the attorneys are going to ask
questions and the issue is was he
answering truthfully and what kirk said
is 100 correct you don't want a juror
going back into deliberations talking
about their experience yes use common
sense but he's not an expert so he
should not go back there talking about
that so there's two issues here was he
truthful and was he affecting these
deliberations and so i mean at the end
of the day he actually could be held in
contempt we could have a mistrial and
this could be started all over again so
we'll see what happens that's what
interesting house plays out as you get
more information kirk thank you very
much for your debut here and terry
always a pleasure thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as you discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you